nearly a third of the workforce are
freelancers and entrepreneurs and it's
easy to see why
when you're in charge of your own
business you can set your hours choose
your own clients and have the freedom to
execute your own vision
if you're ready to be your own boss and
build your successful business join
udacity's digital freelancer nanodegree
program
in this program industry experts and
veteran freelancers teach you the skills
you need to build your own personal
brand and start your own successful
online business in the global freelance
marketplace
you'll begin with understanding the
fundamentals of digital freelancing and
what it means to work for yourself
practice building your own portfolio
site and strategize on how to market
your brand and leverage the power of
social media
you'll work to source clients and create
a project scope that sets up milestones
and expectations and with the hands-on
project you'll have the opportunity to
practice your skills by engaging in
early communications with a potential
client
prepare yourself to enter the digital
marketplace with udacity's digital
freelancer nanodegree program today